And we'll get started and welcome to others who call it is the 27th of July, and we have a number of questions to go over. So here's your purpose right here.
Here's your life purpose on a first desololians 5, 6, teen through 18 pray without CC did everything give thanks for this is the will of God.
In Christ Jesus concerning you so this is God's will for you that we give thanks in everything that we're praying constantly which means we're constantly communicating with God.
Not thinking about ourselves but thinking about what God's will is for us and what we can do to serve him. That's what our purpose is reminder to everybody if you have questions between the zoom calls to go to our blog posts and search for them you could just search any page of our website you do not have to be on the blog.
It's a blog search for it and you'll come with with possible answers maybe I wrote an article about it or did a video on it. So that will save you some time and then everybody should be on our membership site by now.
That's how you'll see all the recorded zoom calls for the last six plus years. And no, you'll see some information of new announcements.
So the latest announcement is the addition of another zoom call Mondays at noon with Ann.
Yes, you can certainly jump on both of them.
Let's get to the questions we have a cabin are making some trails in the woods. That's my favorite thing to do we have tons of trails at our 20 acres and then our other 10 acres of where clinic is.
And so the great kids can run around the woods. But my wife just got some poison ivy really bad. Yes, poison ivy's nasty stuff.
I want to spray a roundup on it, but she won't let me you have a very wise wife. She says I have no business using roundup. Yes, I would agree with her.
Would it be a problem if I did. Yes, it would be a problem if it did.
Course roundup will work to kill poison ivy at least I believe it does.
And yeah, okay, if you use a little roundup, is that going to be so bad promise this stuff has a half life of probably 500 years.
So it's going to be around your environment and it is really, really toxic. It is a major cause of cancer.
So it can be a major cause of cancer for generations beyond.
Even if you get a mask, you wear gloves, you dress along clothing, you're still putting it in your environment and it's going to stay there in the soil.
I'd say you have no poison ivy, but the kids are playing or grandkids are playing they're going to get this stuff on them and in their body.
It's a, it's just nasty stuff. So philosophically, I'm against it.
For that reason, I just tell toxic is and what you're doing to future generations, it's just horrible.
So find a different way to get rid of it. You can just cut it down with your lawn more and it tends to not grow back if you keep that area cut.
So if you have a patch size, you know, an acre makes it a little bit more difficult to be able to do that.
Just have to stay at home of that area. The other thing you can do is rent goats.
So there's services around my area for sure, maybe around your area, I don't know where this person lives.
I don't even know who this person is asking this question, but that you can rent goats.
There's goat rental services now that they will come and eat this stuff up.
So that's another thing that you can do from a natural perspective.
Goats tend to eat the ivy, so it's kind of crazy, but they'll get rid of it for you.
I had radiation and I'm getting the shot to wipe out the testosterone. So the shot that this person is talking about is a loop run like shot, which is hydrogen deprivation therapy.
So loop run and it's similar type medications.
If you have a dog out testosterone will literally knock testosterone down to zero.
And with with prostate cancer.
This person has said that's why cancer feeds on it. There's really no evidence that cancer feeds on testosterone in any way.
It certainly doesn't feed on it, but you can't argue that by using the energy deprivation therapy, you will drop your PSA down to zero like instantly.
Does that actually slow the rate of cancer? That's the arguable thing.
Certainly, there's tons of evidence that though it does drop your PSA down to zero.
That within a couple of years, it tends not to work anymore. So I actually wrote an article about this. That's why I put this thing right here.
There's the rest of this question I have been on the shop for nine months. It's both time to get another one.
I do not want to keep taking the shot. It really messes me up. They won't be to take it won't be out of for two years. Do you have any input? So there's an article that I wrote on our blog post, your memory of search this area right here.
You can search just testosterone and you'll come up with it.
That's the title of article is men's hormone health and regulation. This is actually a part of my book. It's in the can't stop by the cancer book as well.
It talks about the biggest part of that what the testosterone deprivation does, energy deprivation does is it helps eliminate IL6.
So interleukin six is a major driver prostate cancer. So anything you can do to decrease interleukin six.
So that's where curcumin comes in. That's where green T extract the EGCG from green T extract comes in and it is really, really helpful.
If you're going to be on energy deprivation therapy, I always suggest that people take andrographis as well.
Andrographis is an herb typically used for viral infections.
But andrographis has been shown to up-regulate the lupron and its effect.
Remember, I said it tends to only work for a couple years. Well, it can double the life of the benefit of the lupron if you're going to be on that.
So read that article. I go into detail, quoting some research that's out there.
I was diagnosed with multifocal triple negative breast cancer in February after 10 infusions in my first schedule of chemo.
All tumors in breast and lymph are gone, except one small tumor.
Most recent biopsy confirms her two positive breast cancer disease most likely has been two kinds of cancer all along when considering ongoing treatment of I'm going to stop there real quick.
This is why when we do the testing, sometimes we have patients that come to us with triple negative breast cancer and it comes up in the testing is still has a hormonal component.
We put the person on them and often they question us like I don't need to be on that because I have triple negative breast cancer.
Well, just because the biopsy showed triple negative breast cancer does not mean that it's truly triple negative.
So understand what we're talking about. So triple negative breast cancer means the sample of biopsy that they took did not seem to react to estrogen progesterone or her two receptors.
So the estrogen receptors progesterone receptors and the her two receptors did not seem to be driving the cancer.
But remember that was just out of that needle biopsy of that section of the tumor because it made that the whole tumor was truly triple negative.
That's why I don't necessarily agree with just treating totally based off the biopsy.
So let's finish the question. When considering an ongoing treatment of my circulating tumor cells, should I consider them now triple negative breast cancer or her two positive breast cancer.
Okay, so you're circulating tumor cells really are going to be have anything to do with receptor positive or negative because they are still just cancer stem cells and they may end up if they start growing.
They could be trip. They could be ER positive PR positive or her two positive or negative on any of those things. So I don't think you'd consider the circulating tumor cells as triple negative ER positive PR positive or two her two positive or negative because they're just still circulated to ourselves.
With B specific naturally it contains folate. Yes, B specific naturally didn't used to have folated it now they've added folate to it just a few months ago.
I read multiple places that I'm not that I'm supposed to not take folate supplements with horrible receptor positive cancer.
Is this different form or is this something so the folate that is in B specific naturally I still recommend B specific naturally over any B supplement that's out there because it is a food based supplement it's a food based supplement.
So food based nutrition nutritional supplements are different than then then synthetically put together or synthetically drive nutrition that is out there though some of that can be really good.
Food based vitamin B is really important I think from a from a supplement approach now folate is in there that's naturally occurring understand there's a difference between folate and folic acid.
folic acid is the synthetic folate so if your B supplement if you're taking a vitamin B supplement and it says folic acid you have to look down at the bottom and see what type that they're talking about because some B supplements may say folic acid and then it'll say folic at the bottom it'll say folic acid as
swallow tetrahydrofolate okay well that it's not folic acid they just listed as folic acid because most people know what folic acid is now lately the new labels are coming out that more people more more people are are knowledgeable about the difference between folic acid which is synthetic folate.
occurring folate and a laboratory five methyl tetrahedral folate. So if you're taking B supplements and
you don't have cancer, you should take the folate, accurately occurring folate in a food-based
supplement or five methyl tetrahedral folate. Nobody should ever take folic acid. So when it says
at the bottom folic acid, it says as folic acid, it's a synthetic folic acid. It's actually
dangerous and you can see some of my videos on genetic MTHFR defects to understand this a little bit
better. But the folate that's in B specific naturally is a naturally occurring folate in that
supplement and you can take that regardless of what type of cancer you have. That is a safe folate.
You're not getting any more folate than if you ate a salad. So you're fine with that. You don't
want to take five methyl tetrahedral folate or too much of that in supplements when you have cancer.
It's not just horrible and positive breast cancer. It's any cancer. So that's why we don't use a lot of
methyl groups, methyl tetrahedral folate or methyl cobalamine, which is a form of B12. We don't recommend
those for cancer patients because too many methyl groups can be an issue. But the folate that's
in B specific naturally, or this is a product for PHP, standard processes, another whole food
supplement company. They have a B product that just has folate naturally occurring. Those are safe
to take. Is there any way to test our grow-need paths? Seems like they're pretty key to the pro-wave
therapy. We could use a blue light on the iron pro-wave. We can see the blue light on the pro-wave,
but how would we ever know if a wire came loose or something in the connection for the grow-need pad,
and then the grow-need, then the iron pro-wave isn't doing anything. So first of all, if you're
iron, you're even if you don't use the grow-need pad on the iron pro-wave, it's still doing a lot.
So the grow-need pad isn't a key integral part that if you don't use it, it's not working.
It's still working. It just will work better if you're using the grow-need pad. Now the grow-need pad
in the iron pro-wave grows back to the grow-need input on the true-rife machine itself. And that's
connected to the grow-need wire of your outlet that's going into your house. So this is actually
a grow-need testing device right here that you can order for about $5 on Amazon. So these two top
things on any plug-in are the positive and negative. And then that row-needish one on the bottom,
in between those two is the ground. The ground begin connects back to a wire that's usually wrapped
in green plastic in the triple wire component of the triple wire that goes back through your house
wire-need system back to your breaker panel. And then it's connected to central copper pad,
all the grounds are connected to that. And then they are going out through a very thick copper cable
out to the outside and you should have a very thick copper rod, a six-foot rod that's pounded out
into your ground. That's where the word ground comes in. So any shortage or anything is grounded to
the ground. So the ground on your grow-need pad of your true-rife is connected back ultimately to that
circular round ground on your cable on your plug-in. So it is dependent on your house being grounded. So
if you live in an old house like I grew up in where none of the outlets were grounded because we had
wiring from 1920, then our machines are grounded and use those other little plug-in things that are
probably illegal these days that allow you to plug a three-prong out into a two-prong outlet which
isn't all too safe because the device isn't grounded then. So you can actually get one of these
little things and you can plug them into your outlet and you can see it has a readout here. It's
very fuzzy because I just took this off the internet but it tells you if your outlet is grounded.
Now I've been in people's houses where I used this device, tested it and they had their house
all rewired but the electrician was too lazy to actually connect the ground. So none of their outlets
even though they had three prongs were really truly grounded. Well that doesn't do any good,
completely worthless. So they had to get a different electrician out to make sure that the ground
deed was grounded. Sometimes people hit their lawnmower on that little ground deed thing outside
where the grow deed rod is going into the ground and they disconnect the copper wire coming from
their circuit breaker panel and no nothing is grounded either so things like that you want to look at.
So some simple electrician hacks that you could YouTube or Google to fix the problem.
Is it normal to feel pinging and tingling throughout the body from the various treatments, the
rife machine, the PEMF, the ion foot bath, the chi machine, and the infrared hot house? And is it
a side of healing or a side of too much protocol? Patient has bladder cancer, LBD, diabetes,
and high blood pressure. So if you get a feeling of pinging or tingling when you're using
these devices, especially if it's pinging at the side of the cancer, that is always a good thing.
If you're getting pinging or tingling with the PEMF use, that's too intense because PEMF
is electrical frequency, then I would say you need to turn the PEMF down or Google would
a little farther away from the body. That can become uncomfortable. If any of this pinging that you're
doing is uncomfortable or causing a lot of pain that is too much to bear, then you want to move the
rife ball a little bit farther away, move the PEMF farther away like I said or turn it down. I am
foot baths, you can't do anything differently with that and the chi machine, you can't really do
much differently with that. But it is always a good sign, that means those frequencies are hitting that
cancer. So I would not stop it if it's uncomfortable though or causing pain just moves the things farther away
so it's tolerable. For the last 10 to 15 years I have a TATA strict ketogenic diet,
the highly reactive carbs and sugars, and to manage inflammation. I have had not much fruit or
vegetables in my diet. I'm sorry, I have had not much fruit vegetables in my diet, other than a
grazed drink and seemed to find maitainee this way. Periodically I have had low carb berries when
feel it, and also have had extremely compelling to odd things such as raw broccoli during last pregnancy,
which I am honored in eight, and now know it was probably a need for extra colline.
I seem to maintain fine this way, and the more strict keto I am, and the more I fast,
the more I feel my best and thrive. Lately I've had the same intense compelling towards grapes.
Was this grapes or wine? This is not a typical thing for me as the high sugar content in grapes,
but I cannot seem to get enough lately. Is there something in the grapes that could be helpful
to me at this point? I am honoring my body, but I do not want to slip into a sugar trap in which my
body thinks it needs something when it is just craving for sugars that are not good for me. I am
trying to look at all my genetics and see where grapes may be helpful or my nutrition. What may have
changed that is causing this extreme what of grapes? Any advice is appreciated. So sometimes
you will hear different alternative practitioners say, if you are craving something that can
mean that there is something in there that your body needs, and I do do believe that is true,
though it does not mean that that is what we are supposed to eat. So people that crave
dirt, crave eating dirt, where you see little kids eat dirt, that is called pica.
That does not mean they should eat dirt. It is typically a deficiency in iron. So it can be a
deficiency in other minerals too. So a craving towards something can be because we have a deficiency
in something or a need for something. You would have to google the chemical components of grapes
and what are the main nutritional components of grapes. But I do know there is flaminones in grapes,
but there certainly is sugar in grapes too. There is flaminones in a lot of other things. How
could we not craving those? So that is one philosophy which I do think does hold true in many instances.
But also our body can crave things for all reasons. So if a person has full blown stage 4 cancer and
it is gobbling up sugar, you could crave sugar and be wanting to eat more sugar and you are just
feeding the cancer. That would be a bad thing. But I also think there is that in earth craving we can
be craving something and wanting something that maybe isn't something we necessarily need
nor is something that our body isn't wanting. There may not be an explainable answer to that.
So I don't know if there is any specific nutrient in grapes. I do know that there's things in the food
that we don't know about yet that you won't find at any Google search. So that is true. Maybe it's
the fiber and the grape skin. Maybe it's the flaminones in the grapes. Maybe it's the
I don't know. Maybe you do need more sugar. Maybe it would be good just to test your glucose.
You don't want to have glucose. That's too low. So there's that I don't know all the minerals that
are in specifically in grapes. You'd have to look that up. But good question. Sometimes I do believe
we are body craves things that we need. Sometimes I do believe our body is craving things
for the wrong reason too. So some people will say, you know, how could you? You have to believe that.
I mean people crave alcohol. It doesn't mean alcohol is good for us. So there's good and bad for
that. So try to use wisdom and pray about that. I do think there's a lot of wisdom and moderation
in all things too. So moderation and allow yourself to have some grapes and some joy in that as well.
So there's not anyone with that. Question on the chat. Using a rebounder was included in my
binder instructions. I would have it if using it, but I'm wondering what I should be doing on it
and for how long? What is the goal of the rebounder use? I just get bumps in and sweat or heart rate
increase. What is it? I have breast cancer. Thank you. So the purpose of the rebounder is really to
get the lib system moving. That's the purpose of it. Remember your lib system is an open-ended
campillary system and your lib system does not. Things don't move through your lib because your heart
is beating. Things move through your lib because your muscles are contracting. So there's different
throughout that lib vessel. There's one way valves. So as your muscles contract and squish fluid
through that lib vessel goes through that valve and then it can't go back. So the more you can
exercise move your body and get motion in your body. The key is motion. Then you're going to help
with lib detoxification. So how you detoxify your tissues is those toxins moving through your
lib system back into your bloodstream to your liver through the phase one and phase two, phase three
pathways, then to the duodenum and the colon and the toilet. So the more you could help with that
lib motion, the better off you're going to be. Are blueberries okay or is there too much sugar in
them? I eat them daily. So I am very much in favor of eating berries. So berries are good for you.
The different colors of different fruit is the best. So out of the fruits that you could eat that
have the lowest glycemic index, the stone fruits are the lowest. Stone fruit is one that has a big
pit in it. So plums and peaches, they're the lowest glycemic index. But they're not necessarily the best
for us. So the citrus fruits have the highest glycemic index and have the least really nutritional
value. The best nutritional value at the medium glycemic index is the berry. So the berries have
more flavonoids, have more cancer killing properties than any of the fruits. So that's why I typically
tell people if they're making a shake to use frozen berries to taste because they have some really
good cancer killing properties. So eating blackberries, raspberries, blueberries, those are your best
berries to eat. You can have some strawberries too, but the blackberries, blueberries and raspberries
are your best. Is prohydroxylcobolubine different than methylcobolubine? Yes. So cobalabine, think of
that as that's the B12 component. And then it has to be bowed to something. So cobalabine is either
bowed to a methyl group. Therefore, it's methylcobolubine. And that's what we don't want to take as a
cancer patient because we don't want too many methyl groups. Well, methyl groups are good for me.
Well, yes, they are. And a lot of people are deficient in methyl groups, especially if you have an
MTHFR defect. However, too many methyl groups can also turn off or silence genes and we don't
want to express our genes silenced. And almost all of our cancer patients are getting enough, plenty
enough naturally occurring methyl groups because you're eating green leafy vegetables and salads and
you're eating more of vegetables than the average non-cancer patients. So having two little methyl
groups is not an issue for our cancer patients. So we don't want methylcobolubine. So what's our other
options with cobalabine? Well, the next option is cyanocobolubine, which is a synthetic cobalabine,
which nobody should take. So across that one off, then you have two good options. What is a
adenosyl cobalabine? Which is these are equally good or hydroxyl cobalabine? So either one of those
you could use hydroxyl cobalabine or adenosyl cobalabine. They're both equally as good.
Neither one is better than the other. They will enter into the thethiety pathway and serve as
your best use of B12. I had a biopsy last week. I have outside of the restrictions window and have
a closed wound that is bruised but healing. Am I able to resume the pdf and hyperthermia over that site
yet? So long as the wound is closed and healing. I would say yes. I would just watch it. Make sure
when you add heat to it that the wound doesn't open up as all and make sure it doesn't look like it's
swollen underneath there or swelling. Getting any worse swelling when you're doing the hyperthermia. I
don't think the pdf would cause any issues but the hyperthermia would be the one that I was just keeping
on. Any other questions? In animals help detoxify equivalently to exercise. If I'm struggling with
exercise due to the SAV paid and ademic fatigue, do it in animals two times per week. So it's hard
to say an equation here because if a person is exercising, are you detoxifying? So what is exercise
due to detoxification? So exercise I said helps move lip because you're contracting muscles. So that's
how it's helping. But if you're exercising to a sweat that you're helping detoxify through the skin.
So two ways that exercise I guess could help with detoxification. Animals with detoxification. So
animals are stimulating your parasympathetics which what are your parasympathetics do when
stimulated? Stimulates your immune system. Hey, that's good. Stimulates your detoxification pathways.
Hey, that's great too. Do it in two times a week. That's great. If you're having an issue with detoxifying,
you want to probably move to doing it more often than that. So does with help with detoxification
the same way we're talking about with exercise. Not the muscle contraction but the sweating. So it's
hard to equate those what's better, what's worse, doing as much as you can. And certainly if you have
fatigue then don't you know, don't push it and cause more fatigue. Somebody unmuted themselves. Do
they have a question? I'm going to mute you again. Question my breast is really swollen and the center
of my chest is a bit sore. I have breast cancer. If for those of you that have a cancer that's near
the surface like breast cancer that may be visible, it may be good for you to send us a picture. So when
you see something really change like wow, it looks super rad there. This looks really weird. It looks
different. Can you just take a picture of it cover up your nipple if you have to but gets a couple
decent pictures and email them to us email them to info at cutters clinic and it'll only come to me
so I can get it in your file. So if there's an issue that we can that I want to address we can get back
to you. Please put your name on the email because sometimes that's not decipherable so we know who
it's coming from. So this person asked this question maybe that would be a good idea to do. I have had
total and figured out fungus. Suggestive of systemic fungus for sure. So far after four months of
protocol I have seen little of no improvement. Protocol seems to work well though. Are you talking
about the fungus protocol on the rife? I don't not sure what protocol you're talking about.
There is a fungus stuff. I gotta find it really quick because I need to get this up on the
number site that we have used in the past. Let's see if I can find it. The rife protocol you
suggest it. Okay. This is it. I think this one is there right here. I think this one. I'll put this up on the
David. They heard us here. So this herbal dail fungus soak. I think that's the one that I used to
recommend all the time to people and had a really good results with it. Pretty sure that's it. You can
get it on Amazon. You soak your hands or your feet in it that will help too. You can see the
different herbs that are in that in this picture. If I make it a little bit bigger. I would also think
about getting essential oils of these things and try those on it as well. The medication for
thugate, thugate in your body is just horrible for your liver. It is so toxic. So we never recommend
that. I would try these things first. Yeah. We want to just totally just work on that fungus at that
spot. That's what we would want to do something like that. Any other questions? Is it okay to use the
fungus protocol to help with lifelong product problem? Well, also the cancer protocol don't want
to overwhelm the liver. Especially if you're using a soak like this. You're not absorbing really those
things you're affecting in just on the surface. If you're using an essential oil, obviously you're
absorbing some of that. I would certainly try it at the stage if you're in dire
issues that I would say, probably not, but certainly at the stage, you can try those things.
It's swelling of the ankles primarily and other body parts the past months probably due to
the toxic dump from the salve. Enemies and IV might have been see more frequent to get the swelling
down. So if you're having a swelling of your ankles and stuff that is stasis the fluid. So
swelling of your ankles, you want to move fluid that doesn't necessarily mean that you're having
liver problems. It means that you're having stasis of fluid in your feet. It means your
lip that lip is not flowing. So think about doing exercises. Don't feel good and tired. You can
sit and write the alphabet with your toe. Motion is key. So you're contracting your lower leg and
leg muscles. You can write the alphabet with your toe by moving your ankle. You could write the
alphabet larger by moving your lower leg. So your getting contraction of those muscles will help
move lymph. Obviously putting your legs elevated your legs will help so that you have gravity help
move that lymph that will help to. Deweyed coffee enemies will help because it stimulates the liver
but because it stimulates the parasympathetics which is under which the lip system is under that control
too. So vitamin C IV, I'd say maybe not so much. You might want to back off on the vitamin C IV because
too much vitamin C could actually cause increased swelling in some people. So I would say
animals back you were talking to Max Gerson, he would say you need to be doing several coffee
animals a day. So not a week but a day. That's the answer he would give you is unfortified nutritional yeast
okay. Yes, that should be okay. Fortified things are fortified typically with synthetic crappy
supplements that could be not good for you. So yes, you could use that. I am very stiff in the
mornings and after squatting etc. After hysterectomy is there anything I could take for pain and stiffness.
I have horrible receptor positive breast cancer. So yep, so you're made in pain protocol.
Try to stay away from medications would be your anti-inflammatories. So you're crooked at your
buzz wellie on your white willow bark. All these are the flavonoid group. The green T-extract
the sticky metal all of that group. You can find those things in a product called clear inflame.
Clear inflame is our brand of inflatode. That's a good product to take.
The R-A-I product stands for anti-inflammatory or autoimmune. It's just two letters A and I.
That's a product I formulated. It's just got the flavonoids in it for that reason for decreasing
inflammation. The other thing that could help with that is CBD. So CBD would be helpful for that
and THC is helpful for that too if it's legal in your state. Certainly very helpful for pain.
So those would be the things that I would go to first. And you do have to take those
on a fairly regular basis. So I'm like taking you know so if I have a lot of pain I might take
A-I or clear inflame and I'll take maybe three of them and then an hour later I'll take another
three then a couple hours later I'll take another three. I might take you know up to 20 a day just to
try to block that pain cycle and to knock that out of me then I'll go down to maybe four five or six
a day. So you have to kind of get your body kind of loaded with those flavonoids. And remember all
those nutrients especially the flavonoids have a pretty short half-life. I think Res Veritrol is
another one of those flavonoids and like that has the shortest half-life of anything. So that means
it's gone out of your body pretty quick. So you need to take it over time. It substitutes leafy greens
with greens powder okay to take on a daily basis if I can't find good fresh greens at the store.
Yes I would say for sure. So the greens powders that are out there like greens first have
we more nutrients in it than fresh greens. So because it's a lot more than fresh greens. So
yes so you can use the greens. I'm big into using the greens powders. They can be a really good
whole food, whole nutrient, quote-unquote multiple vitamin for us that can really feed our bodies
especially in times that you can't get greens like in the winter months and stuff where it's
you feel in an area where it's hard to get some fresh greens. All right everybody we will
sign off for tonight. I thank you for being on with us. Remember we had a lot of people
sending their questions to Ed or Ashley try to get on the member site and use the
spot on the member site where you ask the questions there that would be better.
It's then I get them and it gets them directly and they don't get lost in the email so try to use that
what you can. All right well everybody have a good day and we will see you again next week.